is Robert Pattinson the new Batman a
spokesperson for Warner Brothers has
confirmed e.t Robert Pattinson is in
final negotiations to play the Batman in
Matt Reeves upcoming film out in June
2021 I love this choice he is such a
good actor and I know a lot of people
know him as Edward Cullen in the
Twilight Saga but he's been doing
incredible work since then as sort of an
indie darling
this will be our paths or are we calling
him our BAPS I like our baths anyway
this will be his first dip back into a
major franchise since the Twilight Saga
ended in 2012 um Edward Cohen and yes he
was also in the Harry Potter franchise
r.i.p Cedric Diggory he is also the
second youngest actor to play Batman on
the big screen just behind Christian
Bale who was 31 when Batman Begins
premiered now for some backstory on how
we got here Ben Affleck played Bruce
Wayne in 2016 s Batman V Superman 2017 s
Justice League and had a brief Suicide
Squad cameo in between he was originally
set to star and direct the standalone
Batman movie you know I tried to direct
a version of it and worked with the
really good screenwriter but just kind
of couldn't come up with a version that
couldn't crack it and so I thought it
was like you know time to let someone
else take a shot at but in February 2017
then took a step back from directing and
Matt Reeves signed on to helm then there
was just a lot of rumors about Ben's
future as Bruce Wayne that year at Comic
Con he addressed the rumors by saying
he's super lucky to play Batman and
loves Matt Reeves but he also never
flat-out denied his departure
then in January 2019 after all the
speculation et confirmed once and for
all that Ben Affleck had officially hung
up his cape and honestly I just wanted
to see him as Bruce Wayne one more time
so I just kind of stick with like you
know it was my turn and now it's
somebody else's turn
he was an amazing Bruce Wayne but there
is passion and good art and if Ben
didn't feel like it was right to
continue then he did the right thing and
also Robert Pattinson he's fantastic he
is a fantastic choice do you guys agree
and
are we calling in our bets telling our
bets let's discuss I'm a - Carlson
subscribe to all things Ichi
bye for now
[Music]